hey what's up guys I'm Kay PhD here so
earlier today I was sorting some random
items on Amazon for a most expensive to
least expensive just random stuff and I
came across this paper shredder which
costs a hundred and thirty thousand
dollars so that was the inspiration for
today's video which we're going to talk
about the top five most overpriced deals
in all of tech so there are some things
that are actually justifiably expensive
like for example the twenty thousand
dollar 4k TVs that we saw at CES they
look beautiful they had insanely high
resolutions but they cost
out-of-this-world prices but they are
actually really valuable they're
bleeding edge technology and actually
deserve to be twenty thousand dollars at
least for right now but that price will
come down I can also see things like you
know studio monitors being a couple
thousand dollars things like that I can
understand but then there are things
that the price just doesn't match the
value the bang for buck ratio is totally
out of whack and that's what this
countdown is about so these things are
just straight-up overpriced number five
is AudioQuest HDMI cables I'd do you
think even know what HDMI cables are
it's a digital signal going through a
wire that is not prone to interference
at any sort of short distance but yet
these HDMI cables are valued and so
highly priced because they have the best
you know pure silver lining and they
have this awesome shielding and they're
just transferring the same exact signal
that a three dollar 50 cent cable from
monoprice provides why did these cost
over a thousand dollars for his six-foot
HDMI cable that is just a little bit
ridiculous I just for the record audio
Quest is not the only one who has done
this there are other companies that have
tried the thousand dollar HDMI cable to
most notably monster cable they did one
as well which is insane and yet somehow
every single one of these always ends up
being in Best Buy and they always have
the most hilarious reviews on Amazon
they made my pictures look better than
my TV faster it's just hilarious but
yeah so that cable is just ridiculously
overpriced number four printer ink I'm
sure we can all relate to this one now
just for the record I just want to say
that there are printers out there that
won't let me print black and white
documents because I ran out of magenta
ink like that's actually a thing that
there are there are printers out there
that won't let me write and print a text
document in all black and white because
my yellow or magenta
ink cartridges out of ink I think that
says a lot about the printer industry
print rain takes the number four spot
because there are actually cases where
it's more cost-effective to buy several
new printers than it is to refill the
same printer with more ink over and over
again which is weird but it's true it's
an actual thing and these new printers
come with ink in them so I don't know
why the ink cost so much I know that the
refills you know companies like Epson
and HP they try to hype it up and try to
justify the cost of these printer ink
cartridges by saying you know there's
high technology going into them and
they're really efficient and they're
really green but in the end if the same
amount of material in to ketchup packets
costs $45 its overpriced
number three is cellphone plans let's do
a little math here eighteen t charges 20
cents per text message and a single text
message is limited to 160 characters
tops which tops out at 160 bytes in size
so one gigabyte of bandwidth can handle
about six point two five million text
messages so multiply those six point two
five million by twenty cents per text
and you'll find that cell phone
companies are charging one point two
five million dollars per gigabyte of
data for text messaging that's
ridiculous and there are some other
ridiculous things about cell phone
companies in the way they charge as well
for example in the United States
companies like Verizon and AT&T and
Sprint and all these guys they charge
you for going over your data caps so
obviously 3G and 4G data the more data
you use the more they charge you even
though it costs less to implement 4G
than it does 3G they charge you more for
it because it happens to be faster
there's a whole bunch of things that are
screw up about the American Wireless
industry but text messaging is one of
the biggest ones because they can really
get you there so if you don't have a
text messaging plan you're probably in
luck because that's really overpriced
thing number two is the Mac Pro no mercy
Apple you saw this coming you knew this
was going to happen but the Mac Pro is
easily the most overpriced computer that
you can buy from retail right now and
the fact that you can still buy it from
retail is kind of sad the Mac Pro okay I
bought a hackintosh built a hackintosh
for less than 2,200 dollars and it had
as you guys saw from the series that I
put it together with 32 gigs of ram 3
SSDs and 6 core processor inside it had
a ridiculous amount of great specs at a
GTX 670 2 gigabyte edition graphics card
anime
using computer for $2,200 the baseline
Mac Pro which has six siga bytes of RAM
a regular hard drive a three-year-old
5870 graphics card and several other
outdated parts comes in at $2,500 as a
matter of fact if you spec out a Mac Pro
on Apple's website to the same specs as
the hackintosh that I built for $2,200
you will end up giving Apple somewhere
in the ballpark of $6,000 which pretty
much earns the number 2 spot in this
town town the Mac Pro is pretty
overpriced and last but certainly not
least deep and dear in my heart number
one most overpriced in tech is the beats
Pro headphones now these headphones are
part of a family of overpriced beats by
dre products starting all the way at the
bottom with the beats solo HDS all the
way up to the beats studios and the
beatbox beatbox things like a like a
boombox sort of an iPod dock all of
these things are very premium ly priced
even though they don't sound that great
the beats pros retail at $400 right now
you can get these on Amazon for $400 and
don't forget there's a beats by dre pro
detox Edition which is a coat of black
paint over the top for an extra hundred
dollars um yeah so now that's $500 and
don't forget there's a lil wayne'
versions the you get where I'm going
with this these are part of a long
string of celebrity endorsed product
specifically audio products like the
Lady gaga beats and the Justin Bieber
beats they all don't sound all that
great and if you can get better sounding
headphones like the 80 HM 50s for
example for half the price you've earned
your spot in to the most overpriced tech
and that's why the beats pros come in at
number one they're made of metal but
they sound like they're only made of
metal so there you go guys it seems like
putting the word pro in the name is a
bit of a curse if you're going to price
it high also I have the links to pretty
much all the things I just talked about
in the description right below the like
button on this video pointing out my
crotch right now but if you want to
check out the things or if you feel like
blowing a few million dollars today you
can do that because I put the links down
below shout outs honorable mentions go
to my macroeconomics teacher who has a
pdf version of his textbook for $200
what the hell the Sony Vaio P actually
saw someone a couple of years ago using
one of these I didn't know how much it
cost it looked kind of tiny I thought it
was a bit of a netbook it cost $900 the
original Apple Lisa which was I guess a
of a pioneer in its time the same way 4k
TVs are but it was a computer that
didn't perform very well and it cost ten
thousand dollars and this watch because
you know there are people out there who
will buy that anyway of course the
$130,000 paper shredder will also be in
the link in the description below and if
you think about it all these things are
just hilarious I don't I don't
understand how people actually buy these
and usually the reviews of them are
hilarious - so read the reviews on
Amazon if you want a good laugh and if
you want to blow a few million dollars
buy them anyway thank you for watching
this is just a quick top 5 video if you
have another suggestion for a top 5
video feel free to leave it in the
comment section below if you want to see
more videos like this feel free to
subscribe this has just been a quick fun
video thank you for watching and I'll
talk to you guys very soon the next one
pace
you